[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everyone and uh welcome to our mini
symposium on julia for high performance
computing at uh julia con
2022 my name is michael and i'm from hrs
at the university of stuttgart and
together with uh william goodall i will
lead through this mini symposium today
we have a very tight
schedule with eight eight lightning
talks so i'll ask everyone please try to
stick to your a lot of times
um
for everyone listening here uh the
schedule is available on the pre-talks
website
and uh well i'm i will hand over now to
william who will give a short
introduction to this mini symposium
thank you michael thanks everyone so my
name is willian godoy i'm a
research scientist staff here at oak
ridge national lab
uh so
today we're going to talk about a little
bit why we want to organize this mini
symposium right as you know you know
frontier has been deployed fastest
x-scale uh system in the world currently
and we are very interested in using
julia at this scales so
in this two hours you're going to have
uh information about the current
landscape for julian hpc we're going to
provide
an informative venue this is the whole
reason we are motivated to do this
because the people
behind these efforts are you know are
willing to share and this is going to be
very important because without a
community we if this is not going to be
possible and hopefully this will be very
helpful to the audience and
having this will actually uh make us
grow as a community
so this is a good opportunity for us to
rethink how we do computed we see this
uh you know at those who work with
supercomputing that scientific program
is really hard especially
the scales we're targeting and so far
becomes our specialized equipment when
we do want to do so uh science
and we need to know enough about the
science the domain and also about the uh
you know hardware this is no nothing new
to this audience
so uh one of my favorite quotes is from
vacuums on fortune okay because he was
trying to
solve not only a technical problem but a
economical problem so this is how i see
julia how it approaches it especially
when the landscape has changed 2022 have
things like ai machine learning
workflows which is a completely
different world from the more
traditional hpc
uh
let me go to the next so trying to make
a case for julia around here and you
know it within our community on putting
on my idea we had we are thinking about
you know how to um you know
take a different approach as as
co-design especially since these are
heavily multi-disciplinary uh problems
that have become very complex so julia
is trying to be a a good balance between
having something that is fast but not as
complex and you know trying to position
it in this squadron right
so it's a very interesting
language that we want to explore more
the community and our efforts here are
now you know can be summarized in these
slides i don't want to go through all
this but this is something that it's
really really important caught my i i'm
very happy to share with all of our
collaborators here this is a
multi-disciplinary
effort we're working towards you know
establishing the you know the
foundations for julia in hpc it's
probably the last frontier for the for
the language and we have you know
external and internal engagements
as part of our preliminary exploratory
work we did some runs comparing as
naturally as it comes julia with ce and
alternative like python number cuda so
we want to try to explore where we are
and what the gaps mean and uh you know
for this community and how we can uh you
know come together and try to address
this problems as you know we use julia
for science similarly we're trying to
test things on on crusher part of our
job is to work as a community for
example give credit to ludovic
because you know we're trying to test
one of his uh frameworks and on our
systems and make sure things can work
smoothly some final thoughts that we run
a local workshop at uh rnl and the
impression was out of the 101 responses
is that 92 want to learn about it so
it's still very new for the large
minority even though they're vibrant
communities so the interests and
momentum are very real that's a message
i want to share with this community
some final thought
i just want to say thank you to all the
speakers for coming here we have a very
exciting uh agenda and you know
ideally we want to we want to be able to
answer the question right like what is
the return of investments for somebody
willing to use julia for their science
at this scales
and once again i'm very uh proud of the
people this community i have a a lot of
fun and i just want to acknowledge my
sponsors
and
please enjoy the the rest of the uh mini
symposium thank you
thank you very much william for the
introduction
so uh without further ado i would like
to start with the
first speaker
the first presentation uh is going to be
by samuel umlan from cscs
he has actually
pre-recorded a video
that we're going to play right now
and
there are different ways in which you
can ask questions
i will uh just show them at the banner
below
you have the ability to use pigeonhole
you can also ask on the juliaslack in
the hpc channel or on the juliacon
discord
in the green channel
hi
sam
welcome to our mini symposium
and i'm looking forward to your talk
hi thanks
welcome to my talk on the scalability of
the giulia tpus tech i'm samuel lomlin
computational scientist and responsible
for duality computing at the swiss
national supercomputing center
intersurig and my co-authors are ludwig
grass and even utkin also from eths
zurich
in high performance computing nowadays
people often mention the three piece
performance portability and productivity
more specifically one might understand
the three p's as scalable performance
performance portability and productivity
everybody agrees
it is a challenge
in this talk we will present you one
part of our solution to this challenge
more precisely in order to perform large
scale high performance computing you
have less the questions noted on the
right here now in this talk i'll focus
on distributed polarization in
particular on the scalability of the gpu
stack
of course i also need to give you our
answer to the question about the
programming languages now of course to
everybody's surprise this is julia
how do you achieve an efficient this
rule policization that addresses the
three p's
our solution is automatic distributed
polization of architecture agnostic code
as the color shows automatic is for
productivity distribution for scalable
performance and architecture agnostic
code for portability
note that throughout the presentation
you'll see these colors and they will
always refer to the three piece
the package implicit global grid does
exactly that for stencil-based
applications
i presented you already this repeat
challenge we want to address in this
talk
now i will discuss automatic
distributionalization of architectural
economic code with julia and its primary
requirements on mpljl and the julia gpu
packages i'll use implicit global
written as an example
in the end i report results and finish
with conclusions
implicit global grid is designed for
domain scientists
it renders the distributionalization of
stencil-based cheap uncp applications on
a regular staggered grid nearly triple
it relies on ampere.jl qhl and mmd gpu
utl and supports cuda and raw camera npr
moreover it is seamlessly interoperable
with empire tail and of course also is
parallel sensor nutrient
finally it uses implicit domain
decomposition
what i mean with implicit domain
decomposition
on the left you can see the global grid
and on the right how it looks like
decomposed with halo regions now most
people start on the left with the global
grid and get to the
local grids by decomposing it we do just
the other way around we say how many
times we want to have a local problem in
each dimension and that way we create
implicitly the global grid here's an
example of automatic distribution of
architecture agnostic code using
implicitly grid we initialize the global
grid by passing the size of the lock
grid and xiy to initial init global grid
then and next g and then yg let us
retrieve the size of the global grid we
add update halo and finalize log grid to
the code and we're done note that we
introduce only point-to-point
communication at every iteration with
neighboring processes meaning that it
can scale operate to any number of
processes
first note that array h can be an array
serial rock array the right
communication routines will be called
with multiple dispatch second now there
is no need for expert send receive
buffer or cuda
stream rock mq allocations
automatic allocation happens at the
first update halo call
then what is allocated is reused until
finalized will upgrade
reallocation of more memory happens only
if up detail is called with bigger rays
or more arrays
now let's have a look at the requirement
of
update halo on api hl and the julia gpu
stack
so for communication via host
we rely on the support for page locking
of host memory
for maximal device host transfer speed
and mapping of host merge device
for access from gpu kernel
and
cuda rockem provided optimized async
routines for example for 3d device host
memory copies
then for communication with rdma as you
see on the right
we rely on its support for
rdm and rdma enabled cuda raw camera api
of course and
abstract device arrays as arguments for
imperial trail routines
to achieve optimization we need to be
able to hide computation fat
communication
now implicit grade is compatible as part
of stances feature to do that in an
automatic fashion
this is how done
it splits the computation simply into
computations of a boundary region and of
inner points and launches them on two
different streams
then as soon as the boundary reaching
computations have finished it starts the
halo update which will be performed
simultaneously with the ongoing
computation of finger points
now here is what we rely on for hiding
communication behind computation
for communication via host we rely on
its support for non-blocking high
priority streams for overlapping access
of hosts and receive buffers with
computations
and
non-blocking of course cuda raw cam
provided optimized as increasing for
example for 3d device host main
copies then
on the right side you see
for communication with rdma we rely on
its support for
non-blocking high priority streams
for overlapping access of device send
receive buffers with computations
and of course also non-blocking rdma
data transfer routines in the mpi
library itself
here you can see the timelines of the
communication computation routines of a
runways could wear mpi on a single node
with foreign media tesla v100 gpus
they're connected enemy link so
that means the empire communication is
going through and we link here
here we zoom into three or let's say two
and a half iterations and you can see
that the communication related routines
in purple overlap the computation
routines in green
now the communication part will be much
longer for runs with more than one
compute node of course
results and conclusions
here we see the parallel efficiency of a
tulia 3d polaris elastic two-phase flow
solver in yellow
and the cuda c solver it was ported from
in blue
so far we run the julia code only with
up to 1020 gpus
and we got a parallel efficiency greater
than 95
thanks a great part to palestini's
height communication feature
achieved similarly good results with a
3d non-linear diffusion solver and the
3d viscoelastic stock solar we obtained
over 96 parallel efficiency on desktops
to
over 2000 gpus
i'll keep the conclusion very short we
showed that using julia and peter tail
and the gpu packages we could
successfully implement
distribution that enables great
scalability and addresses the 3p
challenge
as this talk is part of a mini symposium
i will conclude with a little side note
and with last year we had a julia cheapu
hpc course at cscs
instructors are tim bezar and myself
and you can find all the relevant
information material and an edited video
on the following link thanks a lot for
your intention
so thank you very much for this video
sam
we will directly follow this talk with a
another talk um by
simon byrne from
caltech
who is going to be talking about the mpi
jl package
you will still be able to ask questions
also to sam uh
try to answer
via pigeonhole or slack or discord
but we'll after this talk we'll also
have five minutes
for the two speakers to have some live
q a
so uh simon i'm
trying to load up your slides
oh i can share my screen
uh maybe not actually
yeah if you get my slides on fusion
i think that should do it so uh yeah
that works please go ahead
well thank you for the opportunity um
i
yeah so i'm the
i guess somehow became the primary
maintainer of uh mpi.jl
um and this was intended to be in vrgl
1.0 but we're not quite there
mainly due to i think being cautioned
and ensuring everything works before it
released
to introduce myself i'm the lead
software engineer in the climate project
um caltech
and
yeah i've been sort of working on mpi.jl
since i started there about threes ago
all right we'll move it next slide
thanks
so mbo.gel
i'll give a bit of background um
as a as the names yes it's provides
julia bindings through the message
parsing interface which is i guess the
lingua franca of
communication and parallelism on hbc
systems uh so started by lucas wilcox
back in july 2012 so not within a year
after julia was sort of released
um since then it's had about 60
contributors so what seems to happen is
that people pick it up for a project and
modify it add it add some new features
and then
someone else the next person picks it up
and somehow i'm the latest person in
that change of maintainers although
there's also been a lot in the recent
times there's been a large number of
contributors who i'm very appreciative
uh so the overall interface is very
similar to the i guess the python one
mpi for pi
um which
for credit is a very is a fantastic
library as well um
and
the overall idea is it tries to be
similar to the c api but with some
julian niceties
so the principle one being we try and do
a bunch of other things to handle buffer
length and data types
we generate custom data types and
operators you know on the fly as needed
and we can use julia exceptions rather
than probably getting error codes i
guess those are the principal ones um
the core idea is that we at the moment
we exposed of most commonly used
functions but if you look at sort of the
proportion of total functions that are
used it's probably still abortion
there's still a only soil part so if
there's something missing
poor requester is welcome
um
and i if you want a sort of a longer
introduction um we have a julie con
julicon 2020 talk and there's also a
proceedings paper from that talk which
gives us sort of a nice introduction
into this with the overall ideas behind
that
uh to cover what's open change recently
uh a lot of
most of the work since then has been
consistency in interface cleanup so to
make there's
as as the library had evolved and people
had out of different things there
people had different ideas and so we
tried to make a large numbers consistent
so yeah
consistent naming use of mutation
the suffix explanation suffix and we
also added some keyword arguments to
make some of the interfaces a bit
clearer which
um a lot of the api interfaces just
provide integers so you have to remember
the order of the integers that get
applied so it makes it easier to use
keyword arguments
we've added a lot more apis so there's
uh
as people have added which
various uh particularly the uh
the one-sided communication ones have
been much more much improved
thank you to the contributors for those
and there's been a lot of bug fixes and
work and i think actually probably most
workers go into fixing doing bug fixes
and workarounds for
uh various implementations and backlight
backend libraries and hardware
so i will say that the ucx library is
possibly the main of my existence
um
simply due to how it
sort of it just things it does it's a
sort of a back uh common backend library
used by a lot of implementations that we
you know is under development but often
we find holes that you know that perhaps
people were otherwise unaware of
there's also been a fair bit of work on
the better doctor examples although more
always welcome
and i will do plan to release version
0.2
0.20 soon which is effectively going to
be the pre-release for version 1.0 so
there won't be you know the idea is once
we get uh version 0.20 released it will
be the
final version the closer they're more
breaking changes so i
thank you to everyone who's put up with
my
occasional breaking releases i
appreciate your patience
so i think i'll give a quick overview of
some of the nice features i think
particularly that have come about since
then um so gpu support uh
to gp the gpu support mpi consists of
basically allowing to use direct
mpi communication between gpu devices so
you don't have to buffer through local
memory
first memory
um
and the core principle in mpi is that it
uses the same functions and so instead
of passing a sort of a pointer to a host
device you pass a coup pointer or a
pointer on some sort of gpu device
uh the key thing is it requires some
sort of gpu aware implementation and the
implementation itself may require
hardware that's up to you
um
and so that requires us
using external api library rather than
the previous ones we currently use we
provide by default
um at the moment we support both cuda uh
which i added actually quite a few years
ago and has been whiteboard early use
and more recently we now have support
for rock arrays in amd gpu package
and it's uh so many thanks to the people
who've worked on those
this doesn't rough edges um part of this
is simply because
the gpu aware extensions aren't really
standardized in
the uh
as part of mpi
um so there's no way to actually query
what features are available um not all
functions are generally supported most
common ones are
but
you know and but again there's no way to
query which functions are supported
uh
there's some intricacies in the sense
that you're using uh asynchronous
devices so cuda dot jl for example uses
per thread streams
uh these should be them manually
synchronized before you do any
communication so
there isn't it's not quite a drop in
replacement um depending on how your
writing work
and then
i guess my biggest graphic complaint
here is of all is that reusing these mpi
functions although makes it easy
perhaps on the user it does impose
significant technical imitations on the
api libraries themselves
and so they need to jump through a lot
of hoops and this is probably the single
cause of the most
complications that we have is the
libraries having to work around these
certain limitations of using the same
functions so
i'll leave it if that happened before i
could probably spend the 10 minutes
complaining about this but i won't
thank you
thanks
the other big change um you will see is
the use of npr preferences is npr
preferences package
um so this is the changes the mechanism
of how you select an mpi binary so the
problem is that every cluster will
typically have their own nba invitation
that they want you to use um or possibly
more than one depending on the clusters
cluster
and the big problem with mpi is that
there's no standard
application binary interface so that
means the type sizes and the constants
are not standardized across
implementations
previously we used the mechanism we used
the pkg build mechanism which you had to
configure using environment we had a
bunch of environment variables and then
copy these builds
um this made up very brittle when you
had to switch between implementations it
required a full rebuild
and it also tied meaning that if you try
it it
wasn't really feasible or it's very
difficult for sort of sysadmins to make
it so that you can figure it in a way
that could be used for all api
versions because it was tied that pag
build is tied to a specific version of
jl
so mpi preferences uses a different
approach it uses the new preferences
system um so mpi preferences is simply a
very lightweight package that lets you
select the mpl mpi implementation
uh so you can select between either the
prebuilt jll libraries that we provide
so in picture openmpi
um or microsoft and windows or the new
mbi trampoline package
uh which is a
npi
which
is very active
uh and there's also quite may become
standard in the future
or it also provides the system api um so
i'll give an example here so you do your
system api and you can there are keyword
options but it will generally detect
quite reliably what the api is used
uh and this is then the path to the
library and the launcher and those sorts
of things so this allows for setting um
the preference system is quite nice it
allows you to set uh
system-wide settings by modifying enjoy
the load path and it plays nice with the
pre-compiled cache
and then downstream right binaries as i
said are a work in progress
uh it also works the other
recent change which is not so obvious
but it lets you use now works with mpi
profilers so mpi.gl we've modified it so
it now uses global sequels
which lets you now use uh profilers and
debuggers which uh based on led preload
to intercept mpi calls
um so as an example so some of these are
very expensive and typically come with a
cost tied to licenses or type costs
themselves but the nvidia inside the one
inside systems is a free version
although it's originally developed for
cuda profiling it works quite well
without a gpu um
and has mpi hooks uh so here's an
example here
uh and i'll give a quick plug for the
mvtx.jl package which i just recently
created um which lets you do custom
instrument custom instrumentation um
so you can tag
instrument your own code and also lets
you provides hooks into the julia
garbage collector so if you're having
garbage collection problems it will uh
provide electricity
okay um so i've got a few sizes the
intake what i wish could be better so
what i'm unhappy with the package
printing
is something i've never really liked um
and a large chunk of this is how api
launches themselves merge
uh standard input and standard output
send output standard from
each process
uh and so
it's you'll have you'll always see this
when you if you've everyone it's a
perennial source of complaint and
somehow julia seems much worse than
other libraries i think basically due to
how julia buffering works um
makes it
it does seem much worse than say python
when i've compared some of the
comparisons
um so a large chunk of it is we i don't
have a good solution but i would be very
open to anyone who has ideas on this
and we'll say stack traces especially uh
summit you have about one minute left
okay that's fine two more slides
next slide
uh the other big complaint is the lack
of interactivity so
julia repple is one of its nicest
features um
and
the problem is we can't run a report
from inside an api launcher so you can't
do mpi and launch exec julia
uh because basically the buffering how
they again these launchers intercept
control their standard input and same
output and buffer it is generally
compatible
and tries on my um what's called
singleton mpi which is basically means
you launch api outside the launcher
although that works for a single process
the
features to sort of connect or spawn
more processes as far as i've tried i've
never worked in any implementation that
i've been
that i've tried so
that's very unfortunate that makes it
difficult to
make full use of julia's interactivity
the only workarounds i've seen so far uh
is this quite nice tmpi package which is
basically
an mpi launcher that launches tmux
sessions and then multiplex keyboard to
all the processors
um and so i mean obviously it only works
on a single
node but is quite useful it can be
placed with the debugging api
um equation debugging but not really
much beyond that
and then the other one people have said
some success with these mpi cluster
managers
and so this is basically a distributed
worker that lets you uh start the mpi
launcher
the problem is then the main process is
not part of the mpi session and
again
it's not ideal because then the main
process can't use api communication with
the focus
in the last slide i'll just finish on
and my main complaint here is that
is how to integrate with the julia task
system so as i said mpis primarily use
it in asynchronous mode and so that
means you obviously want weight
but
what julia wait does is lets you switch
to other tasks while the tasks are
blocking but mpi will obviously will get
stuck in a c call
um and so i've never come we yet to come
up with a good solution to this as well
um mpi doesn't provide any callback or
notification system that we can make use
of the air
um so at the moment the alternate best
alternative is to use a spin lock or
block a single heart rate right there
okay thank you
all right thank you very much simon um
also thank you very much again sam for
your presentation uh we have now some
time to
answer some questions here in the stream
yes can you hear me so um
we we're please feel free to uh ask your
question at pigeonhole the link so we
have one for uh let's start with simon
what are the biggest issues that you
have experienced when using julian mpi
on larger scales io issues related to
the julia depot maybe
yeah i to be honest i haven't tried huge
uh huge scales to see what um that's a
problem and
a large you know there is a overhead in
starting up um
starting up i think there has been some
work by valentine others to
deal with this issue and um i'm probably
not the best person of us since i think
others have probably run out of much
larger scales
but yeah
yeah i could i could uh answer
uh our
experience with that
so
indeed at the beginning when we had uh
julia and all the packages installed on
the gps uh the home on the gps file
system
and then indeed we we had quite some
problem um
in in scaling it up to like more than
thousand gpus
and
now we have it
uh on the last file system we have it on
scratch all the packages automatically
and so we have not seen any problem with
that so far
and we have made tests up to 2000
something gpus
great thank you i have a um another
question actually one from for um sam
like
the um are there any efforts to
understand parallel stencil and placing
global grid to 4d
um
well
let's say
let's say delected
the basic model is cuda
and this is
built in a way that with indexes for for
um three dimensions right but like with
cuda and could i see whatever doesn't
mean that you can only
do stuff in three dimensions and
then a second part of the answer is
we have
now support for seller raise
and this is going to be released
released very soon
salaries are
like arrays which
have instead of simple scalars in their
cells
they can have little arrays
or structs in there
um
and when i say little arrays of
structure logical arrays of structs
so the the layout in the memory is
totally independent of the type in there
and and there so there you can in that
way you can have more than three
dimensions very easily
all right well i want to thank both of
you for this first part there's uh more
questions on pinyon hall i also want to
remind it feel free to reach out to the
participants we're you know great
community and yeah let's uh keep moving
on with the program thank you very much
it was great talking
thanks
yes thank you very much you too um
the next talk is going to be by uh tim
bizar from julia computing and it's
going to be about cuda jail update on
new features and developments
it's actually a pre-recorded video but
as with the other videos feel free to
answer questions tim is here
and he'll be he'll try to answer them
either in text or later live
hi i'm tim i work at junior computing on
kudo.gl and other gpu back-ends in the
next 10 minutes i'll give short updates
on the features and developments in
credit.gl since my previous talk at
juliacon 2021
if you have a look at the code quite a
lot has changed actually excluding
non-interesting changes like other
updates and artifacts there's more than
10 000 lines of code added over the
course of more than 600 commits
importantly this was done by 45 unique
contributors of which 25 were new to the
project so that's great
and to summarize these changes in a
10-minute overview i first focus on
array programming features and then on
changes relates to kernel programming
so one first important array of related
changes the support for unified memory
in cuda.gl 3.4
if you've used cuda.gel in the last year
or so you may have seen that we have
introduced a new type parameter that
keeps track of the underlying buffer
type which defaults to a regular buffer
type a regular device buffer as you can
see here
it's possible to use different values
for this parameter which will result in
the qray constructor allocating a
different kind of buffer for example a
unified buffer that's automatically
shared between the cpu and the gpu
and for this kind of buffers we can
specialize the copy to function so that
it directly copies between cpu memory
which results in significant performance
improvements
of course the memory will still be
transferred to the gpu when you use it
in kernel but that happens lazily so
this might be beneficial to your
application
and if you want to play with this we
have added a convenience keyword
argument to the coup function
do you know that this is not a stable
api and it might disappear once we
figure out a better way that we can
support across all of the gpu backends
because for example metal.gl also bets
heavily on unified memory
another memory related improvement is
the ability to copy arrays between
devices
for example we can now allocate an array
on one device switch to another where we
also allocate an array and then directly
copy between those arrays without having
to stage through the gpu as was required
previously or you could use unified
memory but being able to copy it
directly is also beneficial
and since cuda.gel 3.8 that's done
automatically and even better if your
system has support for peer-to-peer
communication between gpus like over the
pcie bus or using nvlink will
automatically use that instead so this
is also a better performance option than
staging through the cpu or using unified
memory
we also worked on support for esbits
union types
so the guray array type generally only
supports element types that are so
called bits types and those are
primitive types that can be represented
by plane memory without pointers
and starting in color gel 3.3 we now
also support storing unions of bits
types contiguously similarly to how the
cpu array implements this optimization
and this is mainly interesting to
support nothing or missing values and
generally we expect that our api
seamlessly supports such values
however it's possible that
you run into type and stable code by
using these values and as a result there
might still be some issues lurking so
file some issues if you run into any of
those
another area that's been greatly
improved is parks race
over the last year there's been a whole
bunch of improvements by roger lew and
our sparse ray types are now in a much
better shape than they were last year
however we are always still bound by the
functionality that's supported by the
goosebumps library by nvidia which for
example is limited to simple c types
and to work around their restriction we
also started looking into implementing
our own sparse array operations natively
in julia and we started with one of the
most commonly used operations in julia
namely broadcast
so let's compare and
have a look at the performance um on the
cpu and on the gpu
so on the cpu we start by allocating two
sparse matrices um random sparse
matrices so the sparsity patterns of c x
and c y are different and then if we add
them together using broadcast that takes
about one milliseconds
now starting with q dot gel 3.9 we can
also do so on the gpu so we upload these
matrices to either a compressed row or
compressed column format and then we
just perform a broadcast
and as you can see it's significantly
faster on my gpu it took 150
microseconds compared to one millisecond
on the cpu and the output is still
sparse so even though the sparsity
pattern of both inputs are different uh
we merge them together and we still
return a sparse output
there's a couple of restrictions one is
for example that we only support um
broadcast between
um sparse arrays of the same type so you
cannot add a csc with a csr matrix and
we also currently do not support this
for ceo or bsr
sparse matrices
however supposed for broadcast should
make it possible to implement a whole
bunch of other array operations so
hopefully by next juliacon our sparser
ray abstractions will become much more
full featured
for those of you who write your own
kernels we also have a couple of
improvements to show
for example it's now possible to write
code that depends on the device
capability
without having to write multiple
versions of your kernel
as an example here i have a kernel that
branches on the compute capability
note that the sv is just a version
number but it's gpu compatible so it's a
simple version number
now if you look at the generated code
you can see that this branch has been
completely optimized away and we just
store the value one and if i switch to
an older gpu with computer capability
3.5 which is at the other side of the
branch you can see that we automatically
generate other code storing the value
too
again this this happens fully
automatically there's no need to switch
between different kernel implementations
you could log just recognize that you
switch to a different device and it
generates new code
this functionality is only supported for
two functions one is the compute
capability function to create a compute
capability and the other one is to query
the ptx isa version and we added this to
good ldl in order to improve our atomics
because
atomic functions often depend on the
after generation in terms of which type
they are supported
so using this we
greatly improved a lot about our atomic
support
one improvement is that the api is now
clearly split into two levels
first we have the low level api where
operations map directly onto hardware
accelerated intrinsics
these functions are low level they're
prefixed by the atomic underscore
and they only take point it's not a race
and what's also low level about this api
is that you as a user need to take care
but you have to export the operation in
question or you will run into
compilation errors
the exact requirements are always in the
dock strings of these functions but for
example uh if you want to use in 16
float16 offload 64 you need to have
sufficiently
recent devices
then we also have the high level apis
implemented on top of this
and this is the cuda dot at atomic macro
this is a different macro from base dot
at atomic and the two are currently
fully distinct
but it's it's much more convenient
because you can convenient and the low
level api include.gl that is because you
can use it with arrays you don't have to
use pointers
and since cuda.gl3.4 it also
automatically falls back to a generic
compare and swap loop when the operation
or the data type isn't supported
that means that with the high level
atomic api you generally do not have to
think about hardware support
and finally we also improved automatic
installation of cuda and now
automatically upgrade to kuder driver
when possible
for example here i'm on a system where
the nvidia driver that's installed only
supports cuda 11.6 but we automatically
upgraded the driver to 11.7
this only applies to the current
processor you don't need any
administrative privileges and as such
it's so it's very interesting on say
clusters where it's typically hard to
upgrade the nvidia driver yet you still
want to benefit from the latest and
greatest good up features
note that this is only supported on
enterprise hardware
meaning not default hardware but it
requires squadron hardware and this is a
restriction by nvidia
itself that's it for a quick overview if
you want to be kept in the loop please
subscribe to the blog at julia gpu.org
where we periodically post about new
releases of kuder hotel and the other
gpu backends and all the features and
updates that i described in this talk
have also been released previously in
blog post on julia gpu.org thanks
all right uh
that was um
tim on cooler jail thank you very much
the next video uh the next talk is going
to be again a pre-recorded video by
julianne samaru
from mit
and he's going to talk about amd gpu
jail so the amd counterpart to what we
just saw
after that talk there will be again the
opportunity for some live q a
so stay tuned
hi everyone my name is julian samrou i
work at mit's julia lab and spend half
of my time there give or take working on
mdgpu.jl
this package as many of you may know
allows executing pure julia code on amd
gpus similar to how cuda.jl enables this
for nvidia gpus amd gpu has come a long
way over the past few years since its
inception and has gained a lot of
capabilities and integrations with
various libraries in this talk i'm going
to discuss where amd gpu.jl stands today
and what changes what changes i expect
to occur over the next few years
amd gpu.jl has come a long way over the
past year since this time last year
we've built and deployed rockham
components as jls we started passing the
entire gpu arrays test suite and we've
generally kept up with changes in our
upstream dependencies many many bugs
have been squashed and quite a few
features have been added we've also very
recently landed a large refactor of the
code base which simplifies a lot of
things that made development annoying
along with renaming things to be less
confusing for users
not all of the changes have been
technical in nature either we've also
had an influx of active amd gpu users
partly due to the onlining of various
amd gpu powered super computers
including frontier lumi and zatonix
these users have been instrumental in
uncovering bugs and sharp corners as
well as unexpected performance traps and
have submitted a number of pr's to fix
them
let's take a look at some of the changes
that have happened since last year in
more detail
jlls nobody wants to have to build code
from source if you're not planning on
making changes to that source i feel the
same way and so i spent some time
getting the core pieces of the rockham
stack built as jls for all those users
who don't have a working rockum install
on their system
by default amd gpu.jl will automatically
pull in the necessary components of
rockum 4.2 as jlls allowing for mostly
pain free experience the only component
we can't ship as a jll is the amd gpu
linux kernel module but most
distributions are shipping it by default
these days so that's usually not
something users need to deal with either
unfortunately building all of the
rockham libraries correctly is a pain so
not everything is available as jlls most
importantly in terms of libraries which
aren't strictly necessary we only have
jlls for rng functionality but are
missing bloss fft linear solver and deep
learning library jlls i'm thankfully in
contact with some engineers from amd who
have been very helpful with looking at
building these missing libraries so i
expect that we can sort this out over
the next few months
test coverage a strong test suite is key
to success when dealing with a
complicated interplay of compilers
runtimes and devices
as far as testing gpu array operations
goes the gpu arrays
test suite is something of a conformance
test suite for gpu-powered array
computing in julia
one year ago amd gpu was having trouble
passing many of the tests in that test
suite for various reasons
thanks to a large effort by
co-maintainer valentin chiravi today we
can boast full conformance with the test
suite this means that the rock array
should work in the same way that people
have come to expect of the q array and
should work with many kinds of generic
generic array libraries correctly
mpi support
many users of amd gpu.jl have access to
powerful clusters and want to do
distributed computing across multiple
compute nodes in their cluster
the
de facto way to do this is npi
kuda.jl has had mpi support for quite
some time so it was obvious that amd gpu
also needed similar support
thanks to the concerted work of a number
of our users especially ludovic ross and
simon byrne we now have support for
rockem aware openmpi
this support opens the doors to
distributed gpu computation in a manner
that many researchers are familiar with
and for which many packages already know
how to leverage
future directions
amd gpu development isn't slowing down
by any measure in fact the onlining of
various new amd powered supercomputers
is greatly hastening the development of
amd gpu and bringing in many new users
let's briefly look at what new and
existing users have to look forward to
as we go through 2022 and 2023
examples while amd gpu has a variety of
simple unit tests that somewhat double
as documentation of how to use the
available features it would greatly help
users if we had a larger set of examples
that show how to do things with amd gpu
showing off the various math intrinsics
host call asynchronous tax task launch
and synchronization
mpi integration and more should be added
as examples to the repository
we can also test these examples to make
sure they always work as expected
library integrations
most of the power of julius gpu arrays
are in how they magically work with many
high-level libraries that users employ
to solve their computational problems
cuda.jl users have enjoyed excellent
integrations for some time now so making
sure that amd gpu users get the same
benefits as important to ensuring our
users are productive and happy
to that end there are many libraries in
the ecosystem that still need amd gpu
support these include the cyaml
ecosystem packages flux and lux implicit
global grid and many other packages that
users rely on doing this will take some
assistance from the ecosystem but i'm
confident that users will start trying
to make these packages work with amd gpu
once they get access to amd hardware
profiling and debugging while something
of a long shot it's my desire to see
better integrated support for profiling
and debugging an amd gpu this would
entail directly interfacing with
rockham's rock tracer and rock debug api
libraries to access information on gpu
state and a way to expose this to users
that is intuitive for beginners and
powerful enough for advanced users
while it would be a potentially large
undertaking the result could
significantly improve how productive amd
gpu users can be
there has been a lot of progress in amd
gpu.jl this past year and a lot more is
planned for this coming year i hope that
those of you who have access to amd
hardware will give amd gpu.jl a try and
help me get it up to speed and integrate
it into julia's ecosystem thanks so much
for listening
all right
thank you julian for your presentation
we now have also some time to answer
questions let me see we have tim here
uh
do we have juliana here
no but he's
online and he can answer your questions
also via text
so uh yeah we have one question for
tim says
how can broadcast be faster than gpu and
sparse matrix
yeah i responded to that question
because it wasn't entirely clear to me
what the uh the question was about so
going on olympia what the question may
be about the reason that gpu broadcast
is faster because we can still
parallelize across
either the rows or the columns in the
case of respectively compressed row or
complex column layout so and then within
each gpu thread we iterately compressed
in the sheaths so there's less
parallelization opportunity than with a
dense matrix but there's still some
significant opportunity to use the gpu
strats
to
parallelize and get some speed up
compared to the cpu
assuming again that was the
intention of the question but i'll
monitor the pigeon link question in case
the user wants the clarification
great thanks have an another question
uh does could i jl support tensorflow 32
precision format
yes so there's a
twofold answer for that on the one hand
tensorflow 32 can be automatically
supported by using appropriate kubla's
api calls and we do so automatically
when you set the cuda math mode to allow
the slightly less precision you get by
using tf-32
if you don't do that then we'll never
use the tons of float implementations if
you set the math mode we'll do so but
only for a select number of api calls
and the most important one is of course
matrix multiplication
if you want your own
kernels to use wmma with tensorflow 32
there's currently
a pr open by carstenbauer who's also
here on the on the call
that hasn't been merged yet so if you're
interested please give it a try and have
a look at that br i also link to it in
the pigeonhole question
thank you that's great uh michael
there's a question for
um julia i don't know if he's online or
he's able to take a video
or we can move
i don't see him here on the
stream um maybe he can answer it
on
pigeonhole
all right
so we can move on i guess
i think a
other question what's the status of the
uh debugging tools for could adorable
and amd the jail so let me quickly chime
in on that
because it's interesting in that we do
support emitting debug information for
kuda kernels but the problem is that
there's lots of bugs in the ptx assembly
so out of out of um
being careful we disable that by default
so if you have if you need some to debug
some kernels using kuda gdp
um please get in touch because i can uh
explain how you enable the debug mode
and what the specific requirements are
in order to debug julia currents
thank you very much tim i actually asked
that question that's what it was
running over but that's great i
appreciate that
all right i've also added valentin to
the stream now uh from mit uh he also
has maybe some answers on that question
yeah for amd gpu the debugging support
works surprisingly well it can be
sometimes a shorter setup but i managed
to get gokum gdp working
and to live debug
code on the device
to
figure the stack fold and i got a better
experience and it was used from cuda
because i got actual line information
for all of my errors um
[Music]
the
bigger issue i have with the amd 2 train
right now and that's a complaint to to
amd directly is that the setup for the
profiler and everything else is quite
annoying and gdp support needs their
custom kernel because they have not
upstreamed uh the kind of support yet
just a follow-up balance this is for raw
cam version five two five
one
it might have been four five
okay um or five zero i think it was four
five when i first tried
thank you
uh we still have time for uh some more
questions
maybe maybe bound in my note this one
says what about graphics and compute
interoperability and amd gpu
yeah i think uh julian answered that in
text
the
support i mean underlying libraries is
there
and it is basically just an amount of
engineering effort but we haven't done
that on the mdgpu.gl site
so that's hopefully something to get to
if you're interested in working on that
maybe reach out
great
and and
i just want to add quickly that we
tested cuda jail on the a100s here and
amd gpu on the mi 250x on crashers so
they're looking good
so congrats guys great job
um
i have a question uh maybe maybe tim uh
can also shed some light on this so
uh some people um who i talked to about
uh using julia for hpc they asked me
um
how do you find the time to work on
these packages like
uh
what's your what's your driving
motivation behind this because um for i
mean usually um people you know put in
time because they they like working on
something or because they need uh to
work on this so i i was wondering if if
you can maybe uh shed some light on this
uh i mean
what made you put in uh so much effort
into uh maintaining such a great package
yeah in my case i'm lucky enough to work
at junior computing where i can just do
this full-time um it used to be much
more tricky because i i also did this as
part of my phd where i was
looking into the the necessary compiler
interfaces to make this possible
and that basically resulted in gpu
compiler.jl which is now the basis of
many of these backends and actually
implementing a gpu backend was of course
a prime use case for set interfaces but
nowadays i'm doing this uh full time
because you can use cuda.gl in julia hub
which is uh one of the main products of
julia computing so it's it's important
for the company to have good gpu
acceleration and good gpu support
with that main product
and to maybe expand on this from coming
from
a similar like path i started working on
all of these open source packages
because i wanted to do research and so
it wasn't able to do what i wanted to do
at the time and so i started looking
using julia i started using opencl.gl
suddenly i became one of the
co-maintainers of opencl.gl
and over time the amount of work i spent
doing research
diminished and the time i spent on
maintenance and working on junior
packages increased rapidly
and similarly to tim i'm now fortunate
enough that i do this basically
as part of my job at mit
okay thank you very much
for sharing i mean i
personally i i can i can relate uh to
to both what what you guys have uh
already said
usually it's uh
you you start uh you know pulling on one
string you say hey this sounds
interesting maybe maybe we should give
this a try maybe we should you know take
this uh nice library and
which is already parallel and you know
try to use it from julia and then you
see oh but then i maybe need to add
another thing to it and maybe need
another dependency and
it's a sooner rather than later you are
the
co-maintainer of five different packages
and now people are um
coming to you for questions so i can see
how you can get roped in quite easily
and especially in the in the julia hpc
community
all right um
is there another question william
otherwise maybe we can uh go on no yeah
and just as a reminder we have a buff as
well
on the topic on hbc so on thursday so
that would be also a good opportunity to
you know
stand the conversation that that's a
great reminder um we will uh we will
show the link to the buff as well at the
end of this session but maybe we can
show it a little bit uh during the
conversation as well
but uh
well for now thank you again uh julian
uh tim and valentin for the
presentations and answering the
questions
uh we will move on now with the next two
talks
they're um from alberto from mit and
johannes blaschke at nursk and
they're sort of bringing the
supercomputer operators perspective
to this
mini symposium
so
i would like to
welcome uh albert
hi albert hi michael
um
i'm i'm really happy to have you here uh
to bring your perspective uh also to
this mini symposium to not just hear
from the users or the package developers
but also to hear from
you know the people who have to deal
with the users
um
so let me
share your slides uh
i hope uh either you can
click them yourself otherwise uh just
let me know and i will um you know click
through them for you
so i don't think i have clickability but
so let's go on to the next
slide i thought i'd first give a little
bit of background on mit and mit lincoln
laboratory i think everybody knows mit
our previous couple of speakers are from
there but
mit also runs a laboratory for national
science called lincoln laboratory and uh
the lincoln laboratory supercomputing
center runs uh clusters on both in both
of those realms and
we
on both sides
rapid prototyping is really a key uh
part to what we do system engineering
understanding the art of the possible
data analysis
building ai models and testing them on
different data sets it's all part of the
kind of the same workflow that uh we've
enabled um it's not to say that we don't
uh support traditional supercomputing as
well like large computational fluid
dynamic models and electromagnetic
models and things like that but
our our focus is really on enabling uh
users that are that need interactivity
and on-demand capability so let's go to
the next slide
um and so from the ground up 20 years
ago we started building what's now the
lincoln supercomputing center and the
mit super cloud
to enable interactivity and i'm sharing
this because this flows really well into
what a lot of us do with julia and our
users both on campus and at lincoln
laboratory
are
taking advantage of this interactivity
uh as a primary basis for using our
system we have ability to use dynamic
jupiter notebooks dynamic databases
online interactive nodes uh that we are
running uh
small and large jobs with as well as a
few other capabilities i'll get to the
end and how we've integrated that with
julia but our primary focus is to enable
users to get online and running on a
super computer quickly
and then enabling them to when they then
run want to run big run and run lots of
jobs
giving them an easy transition pass to
that
using julia and other languages so let's
go on to the next slide
not surprisingly like many
supercomputing centers we offer a lot of
different software packages so you see
the traditional cc plus mpi fortran
a variety of third-party and commercial
codes machine learning frameworks but we
do support kind of as our first class
citizen so to speak
julia matlab octave r and python
and that's because we find that those
high productivity languages is usually
the entry point for those
those rapid prototyping users to kind of
get their ideas into code
run through their data sets
train their models uh ai models
quickly and then eventually maybe they
will run it
at a much larger scale using some sort
of batch queuing engine but for the
first thing is does it work do my ideas
work can i run it at a reasonably large
scale in these high productivity
languages so let's focus on julia
obviously let's talk about julia let's
go on to the next slide
so
um
something that i'm not sure how unique
it is but something that we feel very
strongly about in terms of enabling
these rapid prototyping users is that uh
julia is
installed multiple versions of julia are
installed
right from the get-go and that they
don't have to do any installation
themselves to to get the julia prompt
um what it also means from the system's
point of view is that we have faster
launch times
because we're installing julia locally
multiple versions locally on every
single node our flagship system has 2
000 nodes
um it also means that the uh the command
line julie command line is much more
responsive
and
a nice side benefit is that the central
file system sees less load from the
interaction of the command line or of
the execution
on that central file system
as you can see uh with the graphic my
terminal graphic there on the right we
have currently
five different versions of julia
available
and we use the common linux environment
modules to enable users to load those
as you can see we have a lot of other
packages available those anaconda
packages are free for python and r but
we're not talking about that right now
we also enable um users obviously to
modify and customize their julia
environment um using the dot julia
directory in their in their home
directory um so that uh they're not
hemmed in to what we install as our
rather expansive packet package set uh
with julia um i won't say that we have
everything but the kitchen sink but it
is quite a quite a well outfitted
kitchen of julia packages that we do
install natively
as the latest version for that version
of julia
and we will soon no worries we will soon
have 1.7 available um it's just not
there quite yet
um let's go on to the next slide
there are
three primary reasons ways that um users
can interactively work with julia on our
systems one of one obviously that you
saw in the last slide was the
interactive session command line
we also have a lot of users that use
jupiter notebooks and what we have
somewhat uniquely done though it is now
available in other
capabilities uh like open ondemand
is that we run uh jupiter notebooks on
compute nodes and that we do uh port
forwarding of that web interface through
a web portal
for security reasons um you see a a
screenshot of that here on the right we
also have interfacing capability for vs
code and uh and other um
other such uh
apis uh or uh development environments
um on the next slide you see another
build of this uh with me running some
code uh some julia code within
uh within the jupiter notebook um this
is part of that rapid on
onboarding of our users to be able to
use julia we encourage them to use the
jupiter notebooks
in order to get their code running to to
debug and stuff like that and then we
have a very
extensive online help to help them take
what they've been interacting with and
turn it into a batch job and on that
note let's go to this next slide here
a couple of tools that i want to
highlight for you
that is a little beyond what usually
users have we noticed that our users
were often using um
uh doing a kind of a mapreduce uh sort
of mentality but they weren't doing it
for java they were doing it in matlab
they were doing it in julia in python
and in r and so what one of the tools
that we have um the paper uh the paper
um link is on the bottom there um we
created our own mapreduce capability
that overlays the um the two-level job
array scheduling for the mapping and
reduced stages of bulk synchronous
parallel and monte carlo simulations
such that they the user just has to plug
in where what their what the code is
that they're running where what data
sets they want to run the input data
that they want to run against it and
then execute many many instances of that
they can also then do a reduced step to
collate the results off of that to
produce
you know
gathered results from that
another capability that we have is uh
interactive databases online interactive
databases that run on single or multiple
nodes on the cluster and we have a
capability d4m.jl which enables the
dynamic distributed dimensional data
model
it's a it's a framework for
doing graph analysis and other database
like analysis in a sparse linear algebra
context
and that can run standalone or with
integrated databases uh like mariadb and
cumulo
um so
uh papers for that are down below i'm
not gonna spend too much more uh words
on that but hopefully i've given you um
some insight into how we uh manage and
enable our rapid prototyping users on
mit super cloud and lincoln laboratory
super computing center um with both the
installation as well as the uh tools to
make users productive uh usually within
hours uh hopefully not days or months so
that's all i've got for you
and i'll be online for questions
thank you very much albert this was a
very interesting talk for me
uh i'm sure that uh other people will
have questions uh as well
um
for now we have uh the second talk in
this uh two talk package
which is by johannes blaschke
from nersk and he's going to talk about
supporting julia users on the courier
and pearl motor systems
welcome johannes thank you very much for
joining us and uh please the floor is
yours
oh thank you michael um
i was a little bit uh surprised to see
that albert was almost on the machine
room floor or something so it's
anyway so um
[Music]
so
nurse is a super computing center
that
like lincoln lab has a very diverse
user
a very diverse set of users
and here you see a shot of our building
so we are situated at lawrence berkeley
national lab and we provide the
hpc resources
for all
doe
for all projects that receive doe
office of science funding um and need
hpc resources
um
so
i don't think i can click um ah thank
you
so um
so what that means is that we had we are
hosting at the moment about 900
projects
and based on account from 2020 you can
see that um
this is a mission compute facility so we
are really doing compute
services that are
relevant to the whole of the doe office
of science mission and it creates a very
diverse set of projects here here's a
census of the different project areas
and then if we go to the next slide
uh what what we see is um in 2020 we had
about 8 000 users that were using the
machine and now it's actually closer to
9 000 users um what i really like to
point out
is that if you add up undergrad grad and
post docs
then you get about 55
so more than half of our users actually
early career scientists also we are not
even though we are operated and funded
by the department of energy
most of our users are actually from
universities
um and excited please
and so um in 2020
we
um all of those 8 000 users they
essentially used 9 billion core hours
and they cited us
acknowledged us in about
1 800 publications this number is
actually nowadays closer to 2 000 but i
don't have official numbers for you uh
at this point anyway um moving on to the
next slide um
so um
we are currently
running two supercomputers
corey was commissioned in 2016 it is our
production uh super computer um
it is a cpu-only machine with about 12
000 nodes
um and uh at the end of last year we
started commissioning perlmutter which
is going to be our next production
supercomputer um
phase one is currently um available to
general users um it has 1500
um gpu accelerated nodes um and we are
now putting uh we now
finishing off putting in uh 3000 more
nodes that are cpu only that would be
permanent phase two and once that's
complete uh corey will go offline and
then we will
run parameter for the next five or so
years
um
what you can also see here is important
that you don't just provide the compute
but you have to provide everything
around it
so
our data center operates a
a variety of optimized file systems
and everything is held together using
high-speed network and this network
isn't just for uh
like general networking but but we we
design it also to
provide tailored services like data
transfer nodes gateways
attached to all of that is a cluster
that hosts our jupiter lab instance and
workflow node so that we can also start
uh transitioning users to more um
complicated workflows rather than just
running compute
um so next slide please
so uh just to summarize um what what i
think every what i want everyone to to
take away from this is that uh nurse
users come with a vast variety of
experience with hpc they they can be
hpc experts in computing sciences or
they can be just domain scientists that
that need to use
a supercomputer for the first time in
order to
make their science happen
our hardware is heterogeneous in order
to accommodate a lot of these different
science use cases and it will remain
heterogeneous
and also looking to the future we find
that high profile engagements will
increasingly involve
cross-facility workflows so those are
things like live data processing from an
experiment you can imagine maybe
analyzing um the plasma dynamics in a
fusion reactor
and so that creates two needs
and the first one is that we need to
have a high productivity high
performance glue code um and the second
one is we need to have uh portable
workflow performance and and this needs
to be the whole workflow including data
transfers and other edge services
so next slide piece thank you
so
in terms of the need number one our
objective at nurse is to establish high
productivity high performance languages
and i think julia is a really good
candidate for those um python is
developing as sort of the de facto one
um but if we contrast for example the um
call time
for just calling a a c function from
python versus julia you can see that
you're paying a significant overhead
switching between python and and c
and julia doesn't have
this this overhead and that makes julia
much more flexible right you don't have
to avoid switching layers
if your science requires you to to call
highly optimized c code then um
and then make decisions uh on the fly
then julia can accommodate that
so next slide please so um
before we started supporting julia
officially at nurse
we conducted surveys to see how much
interest there would be in the community
julia
has a long history of actually
supporting julia back in 2017 actually
uh the celeste code was one of the uh
hallmark codes that that used the whole
uh hold of corey and and that
news even made it into hpc wire
and so
in 2020 we we conducted a survey and um
we found that
about 74 of uh users
that responded to the service us that
said that they did not use julia however
when we also asked them do you plan to
use it in the future about half of them
either said yes or were undecided and of
those um about half wanted to use juliet
nurse so there was going to be a lot of
interest in
julia in the future
so next slide please
so we started developing modules that
that
enable
julia at nurse
and as will become clear in the next few
slides we use different levels of
support um
so um we split up the modules uh to have
settings and then actually pre-compile
packages and so
the settings module is just there to
make sure that when someone goes for
example um you know installs mpi.jl that
it'll automate that the system
environment is set up so that it will
automatically build against creampitch
um and then further down if a user
doesn't really want to build their own
julian environment then
we have a julia module with pre-compiled
packages already in the depot path
and so
next slide please
and so in addition to to providing
models we monitor their usage
and
back in 2021 we noticed that the number
of julia users unique julia users has
had grown to about 138
actually now the the count is closer to
uh 299.
next slide please
and and we are also monitoring which
versions of julia get loaded and you can
see that um
you know julia 1.4 is in decline and
then there was a peak for 1.6 and now
1.7 seems to be rising
and so
it seems that julia users really like
the latest version of julia
and so it's this is an important um uh
consequence for data center management
because we need to
find a way to keep up with our own
software release cycle with the the user
requirements and that's also that also
motivates um
creating an environment that allows
power julia power users to
build their own environments
um i mentioned i didn't mention this but
also of course we support julia uh in in
the in jupiter lab
and um final slide yeah uh so uh ongoing
uh work is in the area of uh increasing
the the the fine grained monitoring of
our users in order to understand what
packages they are actually using in
order to include that into the
pre-compiled packages we have a pipeline
for python already that's published
the citations there um and uh we are um
looking to to solve some technical
issues in order to implement that in
julia the other thing is that we are we
have already completed and we're
continuing to to make sure that um we
have production level support for julia
so that means
optimizing julia performance and
including that in center operations and
future research is being conducted
around workflow portability um and also
how uh
non-standard you know non-mpi.jl style
use cases uh can actually interact with
the workflow managers and the resource
schedulers um that we have at nurse in
order to facilitate um
large-scale operations and then finally
i i want to also make a plug for our
postdoc program um
it's called nisap
and uh if anyone is interested in
joining us as a postdoc or an hpc
engineer
i will post some some links and and also
check out our website for uh
for open jobs thank you very much
thank you very much johannes for this
very interesting talk
i'm also
adding back
albert to the conversation who did the
first talk on julia for hpc from system
operators
perspective so do we have some questions
william
we do actually uh one question
is since you're represented very well
the facilities here what are the most
critical issues for
julia users and the facilities
if you want to go first albert
i i think
what i what we see on our team uh is um
maybe twofold one of them is um being up
to date um on on packages some folks
want to be on the very very bleeding
edge and those are often the easy users
to work with but then there's others who
um just aren't really sure what to use
and what to install um that's part of
why we have that those those modules
pre-built for them
um the other piece to it is just
understanding how they can parallelize
um i think a lot of our users on campus
in particular but also at lincoln they
they understand their serial code really
well but then um
educating them
training them how to how to think in
parallel and even just a bulk
synchronous parallel
um
is often a mind shift a leap forward for
them um to to think about it uh think
about many experiments and monte carlo
experiments as well um so that educating
them turning helping them turn the
corner to go parallel is often a big
step forward for them
i also want to add that
my interactions with julia users has
been that they're usually um
braver to try
non-classical workflow patterns
my favorite one
task-based parallelism built around
things like mpi cluster manager
and they exercise the the software stack
and the system in a very unique way
because vendors they kind of imagine you
come with a fortran code you've competed
with our compiler wrapper
and you know
and then someone comes along it's like
yeah i want to add an mpi rank and i
want to drop it again um
and um
i actually see that as an opportunity i
think um future uh workflows will
actually have to go in that direction
um so i enjoy these problems but they
are difficult to solve and some of these
uh some of the technical problems around
um you know talking to slurm via pmi2
can be
incredibly hard because i know this is
documented
and no one anticipated five years ago
that it needs to be documented
i also want to point out that a lot of
these things are
also problems in the python world so
desk is a good example in python
and so far i found that
the julia
the julia way of doing things in terms
of package management is better
right so and if if if someone loads the
um
julia settings module at nurse
um and they go add mpi.jl it will you it
will build correctly
if they just go pip install mpl for pi
without any modifications it won't work
and so um from a management perspective
it's nice that with julia i can control
the system environment to prevent the
users that might not know what they're
doing to shoot themselves in the foot
right um
sure
uh
move on michael or
do we have time for a quick question
i think we have time for one quick
question yeah so there's another one
related to what uh albert was saying
about um
jupiter
i mean uh it's widely
supported and deployed you know for uh
interactive computing and hpc centers
any interest for pluto i said you learn
native alternative among people using
julia
i'll take it back to the team um
possibly um i
we have the that portal capability that
we have is is very extensible and so
much so that we even have instructions
for users if they want to create their
own uh
portal front end you know work with our
portal to to forward um web uh traffic
to their laptop um it's i've done it
myself so it's uh it's quite extensible
quite easy to use so uh
um but yeah i'll take it back to the
team and uh see what they say uh it
probably is an easy lift to add pluto to
it
thank you
thank you thank you
all right
should we move on michael or
yeah sounds good
all right so next it's uh
michael here you're going to be
presenting our work
let me actually
do you want to share it
yes
so uh
thank you very much william
in my talk i will be speaking a little
bit about running junior code in
parallel with mpi
and sharing some of the lessons learned
so the the the target audience for this
is is
mostly you know people who are you know
coming from hpc and they they just
started playing with julia and want to
figure out
what what kind of things will i
encounter when i try to run a classic
jeweler code in parallel or those folks
who maybe have already some experience
with julia and now want to go parallel
and find out what kind of challenges
they might have to face
so the work i'm presenting here was
actually mostly conducted by
two of my students uh lars christman and
nicholas near who are also from hlrs
so
the outset for this endeavor was the
question does it scale so
we had a julia code available for
computational fluid dynamics it's called
trixie gl
we already had it paralyzed with mpi
and
have used it on workstations on laptops
and
now we also have a supercomputer
available hawk at hlrs and and the
question we want to answer is so how
easy is it to you know to just go
naively and you know try to to scale
things up uh on an actual production
machine
um so uh first of all uh what is trixi
trixi is an adaptive numerical
simulation framework written in julia
its focus is on high order methods for
computational fluid dynamics and it has
a hybrid parallelization with mpi and
multi-threading and multi-threading is
mostly provided by the polyester package
the kind of simulations we're looking at
this is an example
it's a simulation of a wind tunnel at
supersonic speeds it's with a
front-facing step
you see uh this is the density plot so
there's some shocks forming here
detached shock here then you have some
shock shock interaction you have some
[Music]
instabilities forming here and you can
also see that we have these little black
lines um
forming around the shocks that are
actually
mesh lines and which are adaptively you
know refining the mesh towards the shock
so this is the kind of problems we're
looking at there's actually a video for
this particular simulation if you're
interested
now
the system we've been using are hawk and
vulcan these are
two computers installed at hls at the
university of stuttgart in germany hawk
is a capability system
with roughly 700 000 cores
and vulcan is more geared towards
industry user with 10 to 20 000 cores
and on both systems we have julia
available as a
compute module
so the first question uh you you might
encounter when you
start using julia on such a system is
where to put the julia folder
now
the the jewel depot path
specifies the location where package
files are located the precompilation
files are stored so typically it's just
in your home directory uh but doesn't
make sense if you if you look at the
super computer system and i think um
[Music]
sam has already mentioned it if you put
in your home directory which in our case
is accessed by the nfs file system
julia actually crashed when using more
than
2000 mpi ranks so that was not nice of
course on the other hand
if you put it on the parallel file
system in our case it's luster
because there's so many small files
we actually encountered some issues uh
like slow package updates
and depending on the restrictions of
your supercomputing center you might run
into quota limits actually
so what are the lessons learned here
well uh
figure out uh the optimal depool
location before doing any parallel runs
and this might really depend on the um
on the machine where you're running on
as well as the application you're
actually using
uh then some observations uh for mpi and
multi-threading in general uh we observe
there's generally a high memory usage of
the julia runtime so just um for logan
trixie gel and ordinary eq jail
after compilation and garbage collection
we still have a 500 megabyte memory
footprint which is quite high so hybrid
parallelization with mpi plus
multithreading seems to be what you
should be doing
however here also we sometimes face
problems that seem to be system
dependent
also depend on the mpi version
on the mpi implementation used
so stuff that works locally or on your
local workstation might not work on your
super computer so uh you have to check
this out
and we also found that using
non-standard mpi implementation for
example vendor-specific api
implementations are not as well
supported like the
big two open mpi and amp pitch
so the lessons learned here for us were
you should really test which empty
implementation to use which one is the
best one on your system and verify that
multithreading works as expected before
doing any major parallel runs
next when you start using julia on a on
a supercomputer
you will have to if you want to maximum
maximize your performance you will have
to
replace some of the
jl provided binary with system binaries
so for example for mpi gel uh the
process is straightforward you can
you know just uh tell the system to use
a different mpi implementation the one
installed on your supercomputer
but in that case you also
might need to you know change the mpi
implementation for other packages that
uh use mpi and then
you cannot rely on this very convenient
jll
system anymore but you have to you know
switch out a lot of binaries uh with
system binaries
similarly if you're relying on packages
that
have c bindings
you might have to regenerate those
because if the mpi api changes
you cannot use the old one anymore for
example that's the case with p4s gl
currently the lessons learned here are
first of all document all your setup
procedures for your users and yourself
being it whether you're a package
manager or a system operator
and as it was mentioned already before
by uh in the talk by simon have a look
at api trampoline which aims to solve uh
some or maybe all of these problems
related to different api implementations
um the next point
is certainly one of the bigger ones and
not unfamiliar to those who have used
julia in serial
the runtime overhead due to code loading
and compilation
code loading times actually can increase
when you do run julia um simulations in
parallel due to the increased pressure
on the file system uh albert had already
reported that they for this particular
reason they actually
do sometimes
have some packages stored in a node
local
storage system also code compilation
itself can be slower in parallel and i'm
sharing some results here that we
obtained on hog
you can see
in this plot uh for one rank so the very
left part of the plot uh the blue curve
that's package loading plus uh
first
compilation time is at roughly 60
seconds and if you increase the number
of processes to 128 that in time
increases to almost 120 seconds so the
good news here is that
it's uh it does not increase beyond that
so once you have
saturated your node
and you go to multi-nodes this times
this now experience did not increase
anymore but as usual when you do
parallel computing the general rule
applies any non-parallel operations such
as code loading or compilation increase
your computational cost
so the lessons learned here are um
try to use the package compiler to
create a custom julius image which will
cut down both on the loading and on the
compilation times and you might want to
try to use the hpc spindle tool which
allows you to
avoid the i o bottleneck by basically
paralyzing access to small files
and finally there's some
restrictions
when trying to do interactive computing
simon has already mentioned that at the
moment there's no inherent api support
for the wrapper
and given the long load compilation
times parallel development with julia
and mpi
is
not fun i would say and uh parallel
debugging you know is is even less so um
so there's one uh
one workaround um you can use uh the
tnpi tool which is uh quite nice uh but
it only works uh with a small number of
uh of api ranks
and of course the other lesson learned
is you have to be patient at the moment
finally i uh want to show some very very
early results
from scaling trixie on hawk please be
aware that this is really very much work
and progress so some of these numbers
were just
were just obtained maybe two weeks ago
so we have quite a good scalability from
one rank up to 32 api ranks and if we go
further than that the the scalability is
still acceptable until 64 mpi ranks now
i know this is not an hpc scaling um i
mean we're not looking at the thousand
core range here
but at least uh from what we can see and
we've done also some larger
larger runs already the parallel
performance of julia
is similar to what we expect from c plus
plus and fortran codes and for me that's
a very good message
so finally to conclude running julia
code in parallel with mpi works
there are some additional challenges
compared to traditional hpc languages
uh most of them are related to the fact
that the the tool chain for uh using and
developing with with julia in parallel
is not as mature yet as with other
languages and the question whether julia
is the with mpi is the right tool for
your personal hpc needs
um well you need to uh it depends as
usual
i would say as a as a as a rule of thumb
at least from our experience
if you have less than 100 cores or mpi
ranks uh you're golden there are no
issues there if you use up to a thousand
cores then
most of it should still work out of the
box there might be some
some issues but nothing that cannot be
fixed if you go beyond a thousand well
then you go into the realm where you
have to put in real work but that's not
so much different from other
from other languages either
and
the final uh lesson learned here is um
that uh
you should really interact with the
great julia for hpc community there are
a lot of people out there um who are who
are working on this who have tried
things before and uh either to to get
some knowledge from them or to not feel
alone with your issues uh it's a it's a
good idea to reach out
so uh thank you very much uh for your
interest and um yeah i'm looking forward
to your
questions thank you very much michael
appreciate it and it's been a pleasure
collaborating with you and organizing
the
uh mini symposium it's very informative
so
thank you very much yeah absolutely next
it's
ludovic russ he's from eta sewage
another collaborator
um
are you ready ludwig can you share
yeah sure i started winter so you should
have it in the streams
yeah there we go
so well
yeah thank you for
organizing this
mini symposium julia hpc and thanks also
for inviting me
um
yeah so today i'm gonna talk about um
yeah
somehow on the moon the application side
and well our efforts to um
basically yeah
integrate
julian as a hpc tool to leverage gpu
computing
in parallel for earth science
application there's a collaborative work
uh with uh folks from um germany
switzerland and mit and we just recently
got a
project gpu for geo funded that will
where we look at frontier gpu
multiphysics solver uh with application
to both um iso dynamics and geodynamics
mostly
so maybe a
short intro on those applications so
those application
they actually share
quite some common things although they
may look different so in both cases
actually we're interested in solving
stocks equation
incompressible stokes equation mostly um
for um yeah either the uh solid earth
science or um like
ice flow motion
there are little differences like for
iso modelling uh
they're like
challenges related to boundary condition
based of sliding
etc while in geodynamics there are other
like there are other challenges
for example related to um
basically um processes um that would um
yeah like govern how viscosity behaves
and how how deformation and
non-linearity interact together
um yeah so the goal of that that project
is to propose well software tools which
provide a way forward in uh in two
domains or isoflow modeling and
geodynamics
but leveraging a powerful emerging
paradigm in each pc which is massively
parallel iterative server
and hpc and in particular here well we
made a project to we advertise a project
that would use hpc with julia to
leverage gpus
and so well why gpus in a nutshell
gpus they kind of um
our hosts like populate the biggest
supercomputer
uh on
nowadays and for example
just couple of weeks ago um frontier
first exo-scale machine which is
basically a runs amd gpu but here in
switzerland we also have a new
supercomputer called alps that will be
like hosting the late latest generation
nvidia gpus
and
what makes gpus attractive from our
point of view is that we have obviously
we solve partial differential equation
on these gpus and our codes unless
someone uses fancy techniques that are
not that efficient actually they are
mostly memory bound in that sense what
really is key is that the devices on
which we
solve our equation and run our codes
they should have like
the highest possible memory bandwidth
and they're like gpus they really
outperform cpus like now this modern
gpus they have like over an order of
magnitude higher memory bandwidth
compared to cpus and it's actually
much easier to to leverage the peak
memory that throughput on gpus
so you may ask the question like why why
did we go for uh using julia and gpus
well
there's a
one there's a two twofold uh answers so
well first thing is the two language
problem but i guess that by now everyone
is more or less familiar with that that
well in julia it's very easy to well
have the same code where we can do
prototyping and development
and then production runs with the same
code because well julia is
as many advantages and along those lines
but maybe
one thing that i can highlight is that
basically using um packages we developed
for example stencil
with julia we can really
like get at the hardware limit so in
that sense we can really uh here it's an
example for non-linear diffusion solver
we can really run at about over 90
percent of the peak memory
throughput of the hardware and that
makes it super interesting
on the other hand for example the
implicit global grid that
sam was presenting a bit earlier we can
also uh scale up our like single gpu
or single gpu solvers now on multiple
gpu and for example the same three for
the same three in linear diffusion we
can show that well we lose like less
than two percent in parallel efficiency
while going from one to over two
thousand gpus in a week scaling on a
kids line uh computer
that's one part of the story now the
other part of the story is if you want
to have like good um kind of scalable
and parallel
[Music]
software you also need a good solver and
you could need also a good algorithm so
the implementation is one side but the
algorithm should also be suited to
actually
perform well
and scale well and uh the the algorithm
we now push forward since a couple of
years and that is premature it's called
the accelerated transient method and the
idea you see it here in the little code
snippet so that code snippets if you
make abstraction of the red lines it's
basically solving an explicit diffusion
equation and we can use this explicit
time integration a subset of time and
use it to reduce the residual basically
solve to a steady state the thing one
can do is one can add a little uh
history on the rate of change and turn
diffusion process into a wave equation
and then dump that wave equation and we
can use this now to try to smooth this
random random noise what we see is like
naive uh picard type of iteration we
would kind of reduce an order a half
number of money to lower totals in
iteration and like the accelerated
transient approach will just bring you
down to uh like machine
close to machine precision in the same
2000 iteration
and with this approach basically we
could uh solve non-neural diffusion or
viscoelastic stocks problems in 3d um on
like resolution that are about 5000 cube
in like
about 10 minutes for diffusion and about
couple of hours seven hours for the for
the stocks problem
and like we got the paper that if you're
interested that got accepted just
yesterday uh so that's all about julia
gpu in that paper so uh have a look it's
open open source
so where we use those solvers and where
we apply this uh these two the julia gpu
development we do so one thing uh is on
the geodynamic side so we're interested
in
kind of
complex rheology so visco elastoplastic
deforming rocks and here we model for
example in 3d brittle failures or shear
bandings when you squeeze the block in
3d on multiple gpus
and you see that on this little
little plot on the left that basically
the gpu solver um
in 2d here that's the plot is for 2d the
gpu solver with the iterative algorithm
outperforms easily the um
cpu-based implementation which use like
uh
let's say a direct iterative scheme so
standard
trade-off type of algorithm
another thing that i'm personally
interested in is glaciology and ice flow
and basically
we use
one of the outcome of the gpu for
geoproject and current work i'm doing is
to try to
basically resolve ice motion and
complex multiphysic processes related to
ice flow
on glaciers and here is a
stress field distribution
on the rhona glacier and this results in
one sees that there is like stress
concentration of the base which may be
related to
shear heating and frictional heating and
which make the glacier slide
now it was already mentioned today while
we do some work to try to get the
uh our gpu stack to scale on amd gpus
and for that we made modification to
include amd gpu support to implicit
global grid uh and like added also
modification to mpi.jl and a big shout
out here to all the folks who helped
also julian samurai and well as kind of
nice proof of concept we got our um
little benchmark to run
uh thanks to william
on crusher system at oak ridge and while
this used am rocking aware mpi with
implicit global grid on 8 mi 250x gpus
and well kind of solving diffusion
equation here but if you have if you're
interested you can look into
the codes and uh how to run the uh on my
github repo
yeah so related to the project there are
a couple of package we develop like you
know i would support for example from
sam and the whole team and also the
support from valentine the mit folks and
well that's just a couple of those like
the most important one maybe
regarding really hpc application but if
you're curious we have a project thread
little website where you can well sneak
in and alter a lot of information there
that you can look up to or reach out to
me if you have further questions
and well it's not about teaching here
but it's about cheap uh hpc and uh gpu
maybe so we
will run in uh this year the second
edition of a of a course which is about
solving a partial differential equation
in parallel on gpus uh at eth in zurich
and the whole course is uh well it's all
done in julia like all the resources are
in julia it's kind of
uses all the web integration and well
apparently students really enjoyed it so
we are like super motivated to to to go
for the second edition and well as i
wrote it down in the discord chat the
the philosophy for that course is what i
teach julia basically teach hpc and gpu
in a hands-on approach and this is only
possible with julia i guess for now so
it's really cool
uh well and with this i'm
at the outlook so well we have the gpu
for geoproject that puts a frame to push
forward um well many hpc and gpu-related
uh development in julia and a big thanks
to everyone that kind of contributes uh
also to sam
uh what we've got what's gonna happen
next we'll further develop well part of
the stencil implicit global grid for
sure but we have also recent work that i
presented yesterday on actually some gpu
hpc optimization using a d with enzyme
and in this transient framework you can
like pretty much straightforward make a
joint inversion by really leveraging
enzyme on gpus and it just worked like a
couple of days ago so we were super
excited and it scales
and yeah we do some other stuff like try
to explore hybrid fd and uh finite
element things for uh just capturing
crazy geometries but that's more to come
so well thank you for attention and if
you want to stay tuned please yeah have
a look at that um link to our uh project
website
oh thank you very much a little bit this
is great thanks michael actually we have
questions for both of you sincere um
years uh once for michael um
could you cover briefly what are the
requirements to that julia code that is
currently using distributed to use mpi
technologies
that's actually a very good question
that i'm not really the most qualified
person to answer because we actually
never tried that
as far as i know there is an mpi
classroom manager that
is able to do this but i
maybe we can ask someone else and who
might shed some more light on this so
maybe we go to the next question and uh
we'll see if we have someone here who
can answer that another another question
is uh any experiences with package
compiler to avoid this
just in time code loading compilation
related overheads
yeah
um
so or ludwig do you want to enter
well
please but please go ahead and put out
something if needed
so
we had uh we did some experiments with
using a package compiler and what we
could see is that
if you if you so with package compiler
you typically have your
you set up a little script that you can
run and then a package compiler will
record
all the
all the code that has been loaded all
the functions that have been executed
and store all this code in in a sys
image
now
what we saw when when using package
compiler is that it's
possible to completely eliminate the
time that you spend on using packages so
if you especially if you have a couple
of heavy dependencies like flux gel or
ordinary dfq gel that already helps
quite a lot and if you prepare your uh
if you prepare your sys image in a
proper way you can also cut down
considerably on the on the compilation
time um
we're not able to to
completely you will not be able to
completely eliminate the compilation
time
um unless you run the exact same
simulation and store everything in your
package but just by you know
storing all your dependencies in this
image
is already a great help
in my opinion
thank you i have um one for a little bit
how difficult it is for students to
learn gpu concepts
using julia since that's part of the
curricular teaching
yeah
well um
interestingly
we we didn't see much much friction
there
because maybe we also
as i said like our our philosophy was to
really
um yeah make it like uh
like a field experience like for people
who do like for example but it's it's a
concept in in earth sciences or geology
when we do like some people do lab work
and some other people they like to go in
the field with a hammer and do some all
um
sampling etc so the our approach to
teaching julia hpc are
gpu hpc sorry with julia is really like
more hands-on so we try to make it very
limited on the theory but since well
all the interactivity i would say of
julia
we really let them play and well figure
out the things and especially
for example
[Music]
using part of stencil is really one
thing that helps a lot there because it
has this ability to have a single code
that would run both on a single threaded
cpu multi-threaded cpu and then on the
gpu so they can really well
first maybe start with some fake
parallelization to just get
well get some idea
and then really just try to write a
little code and play with it and see how
how it works and then either you can do
it like like this directly in the rattle
or we have also some
some notebooks that you can just execute
and we'll see by yourself that in some
cases performance really good in other
cases performance is really bad and yeah
that's it and so i guess that
for now it worked like
to try with this different approach so
instead of trying to um
kind of show them all the possibilities
and then pick one we rather kind of
motivate one that we know that works and
at some point when they're kind of uh
well when they experienced with it and
kind of could convince themselves that
it works well then you can try all the
other things that that won't work
or won't work as well and with this
approach it's actually well you really
managed to throughout one semester bring
them from well
basic well i did some python once in my
life or i kind of turned on i did a
little bit of i was using matlab or
julia for one project to to actually
make them code up some well i don't know
something like 3d not the stalks etc
but yeah like i guess that's that's
really one of the thing and where julia
is really
important there it's it's really
it really is a playground so you can
really you don't have to teach them
lengthy concept they can you can just
like tell them one thing and they can
try it themselves and and see and i i
guess that's really the three one one
one important point that makes life
easier
okay if i may if i may add one one more
thing because um
i just saw a question uh pop up on uh
pigeonhole uh where someone asked if uh
is where someone essentially asked if if
julia code and how how the performance
compares to traditional c plus plus and
fortran codes and i think this is uh
this this is really important i mean
what you said ludovic it's very easy for
students and for users in general to you
know to to get to know julia by playing
around with it and uh you can do this
without
uh you know sacrificing any of the
serial performance at least
um so
we did some studies with trixie and
we we really pitted against a mature
fortran code and we saw that there is
there is virtually no difference in
performance it really depends in the end
how many hours more you spend tuning one
or the other codes so there's not
serial performance is not the reason not
to use julia so this is one one of the
questions i get a lot of times from
folks
in the traditional hpc world i i would
say and the speed compared with the
simplicity i think that's a really great
asset
yeah that's um that's a good point like
um well before using
julia and so the reason one reason we're
now really also for projects switch
totally to julia and julia plus gpu is
that for the first time
we tried many things so i was we're
doing mostly things in well c and cuda
or a bit of fortran and kudup is mostly
c and cuda we had like our did some
little libraries that would do the stuff
how we want like close to hardware limit
um and
then we were like
really looking if there is a higher
level language where one could kind of
combine both and well
basically julia is for the first time
that you can write
like
super short codes like let's say python
or matlab like codes like super short
but well when you you have to do it
right but then you can really get the
same performance or with gpu actually
cuda jl in some cases we like slightly
outperforms
uh c cooldown same implementation just i
guess because how maybe um the gpu
compiler in in
gpu does the thing which is a bit
different than what nvcc would do but
yeah that's really that's really new new
capabilities and and if one can motivate
that especially for students then
they're like
they really like it yeah thank you very
much both um michael give it back to you
we're almost done yeah we're almost done
uh with the official part um of this
mini symposium so i would like to invite
back
all the speakers
who have presented here
and by inviting back i mean i will just
add them
back to the stream
also some of the people who
did not speak today but um who are
part of the julia for hpc community uh
who have been involved in um
uh pidgin pitching this mini symposium
to the julia con organizers
and i think everyone who who's online we
have everyone here in the room
so i um maybe we can use these a few
more minutes while there's still
interest also from the audience to field
some more questions
maybe some questions on pigeonhole or
discord that have not been answered yet
i for once
have been asked uh
a a question
um
but that that was already partially
answered by ludwig so one question was
are there any
um scientific project with funding which
which uh rely on julia outside of the
computer science world so um you know
going into the application world
are there any projects and i think
ludwig the gpu for geoproject qualifies
as one of these projects right
yeah exactly well i guess it's maybe um
a bit hybrid so it's still a call that's
emitted so it's a call from the
from the from the eth so the technical
university here in switzerland uh but
together with the computing center
um and it
kind of it fills the gap at least we
have i don't know for europe but he's in
switzerland it filled that gap that for
a long time now uh the well science
regular science foundation would really
prohibit or refuse funding
scientific software development because
well does the problem solve there is
what's needed etc and now we see that
well in the recent years with all i
guess also all this new data and all the
processing needed that well basically
there's not much way around using
computers to do science nowaday uh they
really now try to push a bit like uh
ford again
and well this call is the peaceful
project is a mixture between computer
science but it has it needs and
it needs some uh targeted the main
science application and and yeah and on
that side what we were also super so we
were a bit um
careful with pushing julia too much
because we were afraid that it would be
somehow not not appreciated as it should
by maybe the review panel because it
would bring something new that may have
some resistance and we were actually
super surprised because the julia part
that we that we didn't put too much in
the spotlight to to to play it safe was
actually what was picked up and was
really pushed forward by the by the
panel that reviewed it so yeah i guess
that was a super um very um motivating
signal
and maybe maybe to uh add a another part
to a potential answer to this question
is despite the fact that this is the
julia hpc mini symposium when many of us
represent hpc centers and we you know
tend to go large scales to thousands of
nodes and thousands of gpus right uh
there are lots of science projects which
also run on super computers which are
not you know super large scale not you
know not worth mentioning in the sense
that uh they they break records of any
kind um however they are real right and
uh there are quite a bunch that i know
that use julia and they are funded they
are not funded for julia of course right
because it's a science project and
essentially they don't care which which
language you use to you know uh
implement your algorithm in um but also
speaking personally you know i've used
julia as a physicist on clusters right
so i if we expand the question in that
regard i don't know if it was meant in
that regard right uh then there are
quite a quite a number of codes that i
could name that use julia and run on hvc
clusters
one one project i would like to
highlight that is the sessmix
psap center here at mit and that's a
multiscale material simulations
so it's an application development it is
using junior but and so we do hpc
research as part of it but the driving
factor is an application
and and also at nurse
based on the tickets that that come in
um
it's uh
clear that um in certain spaces like an
astro uh
um
i think in cosmology it's one of those
spaces where
um
you start to see sort of little groups
develop and and we out so i guess what
i'm saying is our power users our junior
power users usually come from like this
one group over there and then um i
noticed that we have i don't want the
name names because i have not permission
to name names but
um you know we have uh some power users
they come from this area and i can sort
of see little little clusters pop up
somewhere else
and so
[Music]
that's the reason why i think it's also
important for hpc centers to monitor
which codes run as part of what
projects
um to
you know
tickets are a great way of seeing who
who has what questions but maybe
someone's using it just happily and
doesn't need to ask questions and i
still need to know you know how how are
they using julia and how can we make
that support better
i think that's uh that's a very good
point and
one of the
one of the
recurring uh
questions that i also get
from my colleagues for example in
stuttgart is
so um
who are the users like who are the users
who do um
who do use julia for hpc
um what kind of codes do they use is is
it
something that is typically
embarrassingly parallel or are there
users who do complex simulations that
would you know
10 years ago be done with a c plus plus
code
and i think this is also where the judy
for hpc community can still
you know improve
where we can still improve by you know
putting these codes that are already
existed that are available that are used
and make them more prominent and make
sure that other people see okay there is
there is precedence and people are using
it
maybe that's a good uh you know intro to
the
community slide that we have prepared
michelle right since you speak to the
community right it would be great to
hear back from the community
that's a good point uh yes thank you
very much carsten maybe you can
introduce it yourself
oh yeah sure okay so uh you know
first of all obviously we all hope that
you like today's mini symposium right
and uh
we obviously uh
would also like to hear from you you
know um that you get in touch with us
the community for example share such
codes that michael uh michael just
addressed maybe there are some that we
are not aware of
or not aware enough and there are a
bunch of ways that you can get in touch
the first one is uh you can go to the
julia slack there's an hbc channel
hashtag hbc
uh where essentially all of us here are
uh you know available
and of obviously many more uh then we
have a monthly julia hbc call i believe
the info last tuesday of the month is
technically not correct correct me
valentine if i'm wrong but like it's you
know about correct let's put it that way
tuesday
it's the fourth tuesday of the uh the
month okay so that's the precise
definition in any case if you click on
that link right there you will always
find the correct calendar entry
uh and lastly uh and perhaps you know
most importantly at least in this week
uh we have a birth of feather session on
thursday coming up uh which will be you
know much more focused on uh you know
discussions uh as it's the nature of
these buffs so thursday uh 4 30 p.m utc
uh so you have to convert it to your
local time zone um and we also put the
pre-talks link here so it would be super
super cool to uh hear back from from
some people who attended today uh get
some input um even more questions and uh
yeah hope to see you there guys
so
one thing i want to add is uh alan
edelman he had a question
right and for everyone says
julia has so much great parallelism that
it becomes a problem for teaching
parallel computing
students are confused what to use when
should this be solved with higher level
blogs documentation etc or through
higher level
interfaces
or both
just drawing this question there for now
i mean one one part of the question or
part of the answer we already discussed
in our monthly call right and that is uh
to basically
provide a better we need to provide a
better entry point for for people to you
know navigate around in the julia
parallel julia hpc whatever you want to
call it universe
uh and there's something in the pipeline
uh so uh
technically you can already find bits of
it but i i think at some point when
everything is polished we will um you
know send out an announcement of some
kind for a new website that hopefully
will serve as such entry point and and
even more
um yeah but on the technical side maybe
someone else will want to comment yeah
yeah and i would like to say there was a
question uh
at some point about how to contribute to
the hbc community in julia and if you're
interested and as an example on working
on this resources for teaching and
highlighting the progress reach out to
one of us
i think that's one of the most impactful
contributions what one could make
i want to
provide my own perspective in terms of
the question
i think for hpc there is a lot of
benefit to teaching a diversity of
approaches
um and so
i think julia is a great example of a
language
that that provides you with a lot of
different approaches to to parallelism
um
all within the same language
and so
um
i don't
if you're looking for
what to teach first i don't know but i
think uh
users
encounter the biggest problems in hpc
when the hardware doesn't match their
approach to parents
that they are actually
when when the hardware doesn't match the
project and that they're familiar with
and therefore you should teach
excuse me
i'm very sorry to hear you honest uh
you're having some issues
i'm sorry
no no you're fine
anyway really bad timing
so uh
um i i just um
i think you get the point though right
like
hardware is diverse approaches at
diverse things are only going to get
more diverse in the future so we need to
make sure that people are capable of
thinking in different ways and
capable of using those
all right
so i i don't see any more uh questions
uh
popping up that uh
have not uh oh wait there's one last
question maybe we can take this one
um what tools or practices are available
for beginner hpc users
to debug julia parallelization errors
for example
you should be using everywhere here you
didn't allocate enough cpus causing a
segfault etc etc
so tools or practices
for beginner hpc users to debug julia
paralyzation errors
any experience here in this group who
may be someone who can share some
some of their own experiences
so
i i got this question recently and i
would a fairly lengthy
reply on this course um about the
uses of example of like ad everywhere
because i've seen in the past that this
becomes one of the most
often occurring errors um in writing
junior programs if you're using
um
distributed.gl or even mpi.gl right what
you need to keep in mind is that you
don't not not just have distributed data
but you have distributed program state
and so you're doing package loading on
each process that you started
and so with mpi.gl
it's kind of nice because the package
loading is happening at on every process
as long as you don't have any control
flow that depends on the rank of the
node
now on distribute.gl that's not the case
um right distributor gl is a little bit
more flexible it
allows you to start processes after
you've already done some work and i've
seen often enough that one of the
biggest issue people run into
is that they
[Music]
set up some state on the primary note
and then start a whole bunch of other
notes
send overcome
work and then wonder why the state is
mismatched and it's not the data state
it's the like the state of the run time
on the other side
and so um
uh i can try to find a link to to that
discuss article but i mostly describe my
workflow to make sure that i don't
encounter these kinds of issues by
separating out
what is the program
what is the runner for the program that
needs to set up all of the distributed
states and so as an example i want to
minimize the use of at everywhere
because it lends itself to these kinds
of issues much more so you often will
hear me say that one of the my least
liked features in julia is that
everywhere because it
often it is very handy but it also
can turn into a rather big shotgun
well
i just want to add something very quick
because i see a lot of great talks and
one best practice this applies to any
language right don't reinvent the wheel
try to use optimized packages that
people here for example have put a lot
of effort right to tackle that so that
will be your first piece of advice i see
that a lot in in some of the libraries
that we work on and
uh
just use blasts or cool glass if you
know
if uh
if you can or cuda and jl and pi.jl
don't reinvent the wheel
maybe it might be a final comment which
sort of avoids the direct question but
hopefully is still helpful and that is
uh don't you know don't scale up too
quickly don't don't take shortcuts you
know go in steps uh you know some a
common mistake in parallelization is
that your serial code is not even hasn't
gotten uh as much love as it should have
gotten right so then errors they should
have full unfold right at the right
level
so uh you know once you go parallels you
you should better be sure that you know
the serial aspects of your code they are
not causing any issues right so go in
steps don't scale from you know one rank
to i don't know a thousand ranks but you
know just go go in steps and that i
think makes debugging easier as well
thank you very much carsten i think
these are excellent closing words uh for
this mini symposium
don't go
too fast don't try to debug your serial
problems when running on a hundred or
thousand cores
that is true for any uh parallelization
effort in any language i think
thank you very much uh again everyone
present here um
for joining today for uh presenting your
work uh for uh putting in the effort to
also answer the community questions
um before we go out uh i will uh put up
the
the slide again with the links uh to the
julia community and also to the uh birds
of a feather session which will take
place
uh day after tomorrow on thursday
at uh julia khan and uh where i hope uh
some of us uh will be present again and
which will be a great opportunity to
also get in touch uh more with the
people and ask some live
face-to-face questions
thank you very much also william uh for
co-organizing and co-hosting this uh
this mini symposium
do you uh want to add uh something
william as uh some closing remarks
that i'm just very uh proud of this
community i really enjoy the
interactions uh you know i i one of the
things that i tell people like one of
the things i'm proud about is that i
might be one of the oldest if you you
know
not consider alan or or jeff you know
and that that tells you something right
that there's a new generation new wave
to
of people trying to do you know solve
the problems of of the past and i i
think that's how we should start seeing
the uh julia right as an investment in
your wider portfolio right
so yeah
thanks thanks a pleasure to interact
with all of you
thank you very much
all right everyone then uh
we're off for tonight uh have a have a
nice day have a nice evening and uh hope
to see you
at juliacon again
great job michael thank you bye everyone
you